here's what I want to know have you
called the children I've even had a
chance to talk to know they dragged me
in here first
I haven't got a chance I'm gonna only
have my phone Anja has everything angela
has your phone you got my phones you got
my camera she's got everything I got
nothing
how's the saying I'll call them for you
right now hold hold on Paula toss my
phone toss my phone call take a second
to call your family near this court you
know you're live your live on ET your
live on et Rob I'm on yeah put the kids
on did you Wow later hey Slater with
Bronwyn I love you too okay then let me
go now
okay okay man I love it okay love you
bye bye that'll get you every time
that'll get that almost got me that
almost got me whoa that's C and if you
want to know what life is all about
right there right there in the the
larger lesson was as I said I mean win
lose or draw if I come home with a
wonderful if I don't I'm still a winner
and they were like okay Dan all right
that's the message no that's the best